[Music]  hey drew john canel from preppy kitchen  here with my cookbook recommendation for  you julia child mastering the art of  french cooking it's one of the classics  and it is a treasure trove of nostalgia  and love and amazing recipes that you  need to try my favorite recipe from this  book which i might like you to try is  the souffle chocolate a chocolate  souffle it sounds so intimidating but  it's a chocolate cloud that'll dance on  your tongue and i know you can do it  i've been working my way through this  book for years i haven't tried some of  the recipes including like the deboning  the whole chicken and flaying it out  situation but you could do it i hope you  enjoy the book thank you so much for  letting me do the show and i'll see you  soon  [Music]